the steam a lot of people often
underestimate the importance of stowing
cargo safely says car tester I know
Dyson alpha most people just pack
everything in and drive off but if they
get into an accident they could find
themselves liable for serious money plus
wrongly stowed cargo can endanger the
lives of passengers and Driver the rules
are clear luggage must be secured
sufficiently to withstand the
centrifugal forces when driving around
bends and remain secure in an emergency
stop anything this only applies to
professional truck drivers has high note
but in many countries the law applies
equally to both private and commercial
usage so how can he still cargo safely
so that he's not posing a risk to anyone
the basic rules are always use a vehicle
suitable for and capable of taking the
cargo you want to transport items need
to be distributed evenly with heavier
items at the bottom and lighter objects
on time Sybilla Foxe and never overload
your car consult your registration
papers to find out the maximum overall
weight allowed for your car plus cargo
was not obstruct your vision or access
to the controls by enticing or exceed
the prescribed dimensions under German
law if your cargo extends more than a
metre over your rear lights you have to
attach a red warning sign to alert other
road users
oohs and ahhs feeling very heavy items
25 kilos or more should be placed behind
the driver's seat or in the footwell of
the front passenger seat if empty and
then wedged so it can't move in station
wagons a solid mesh screen divider or
the very least a net should be set up
between the cargo area and the passenger
cell the stability of the rear seats can
be increased incidentally by attaching
the seat belts diagonally the most
important thing is to secure the cargo
lashing straps load securing nets and
non-slip mats are very useful here
smaller items are things that can't be
packed evenly are best placed in a crate
or box
the special attention to every day
lightweight items in your car it's not
things like drink crates that cause most
injuries but much smaller items like
smartphones even at a moderate speed the
weight of the object has multiplied
dozens of times over in this case that
would be 16 kilos which could be painful
but we don't just use space in our car
for luggage it's often a real dog's life
for man's best friend when it comes to
vacations Abba around half of all dog
owners take their canine friend on
holiday with them and on day to day
excursions anyway if your dog shows
symptoms like restlessness panting or
nausea even on short journeys then it
might be prone to travel sickness dogs
are as susceptible to the condition as
humans are what your vet can help Baba
blue Costa Debbie's a bunch Yost
positive a cut you can get tablets from
a vet like Bettina I taught you need to
give them to the dog shortly before you
leave and one dose is normally
sufficient for both the journey there
and back if you're going on a longer
trip or you're on holiday and taking
lots of day trips then you have to give
the dog a tablet each time so that your
dog is able to enjoy the holiday to
understand and mosman height e to close
alert or annoyed pondan on Dan Soder
diamond osteo dog's house of asthma dogs
are sensitive to weather conditions so
try to avoid driving in the full midday
Sun and never leave your pet alone in
the car when it's baking hot if you have
a crash while traveling at 50 km/h an
animal in the car will go flying through
the cabin with a force many times its
own body weight a 20 kilo dog would have
an impact of half a ton so for all dog
owners the question is not if but how to
secure their dog when driving
or smaller dogs transport boxes are the
most suitable option they need to have a
closable door and a non-slip mat
underneath although boxes like this are
relatively expensive and take up a lot
of space in the trunk the cheapest
option is a special dog seat belt they
are available for every size of animal
and can be attached to regular seat
belts but they must never be fastened to
the dog's collar instead you need a
harness tonga doesn't off then there are
partitioned grills they're mostly
adapted to a particular car model and
use the fixtures already available in
the car for optimum safety they can be
assembled easily without going to a
workshop if your dog is quite lively a
partitioned grill is better than a dog
box as it offers more room to move which
is especially important on longer
journeys